-It's just always
a delight to see you.
You were here 10 months ago.
-Yes.
-And a very
surreal thing happened,
which is,
the day you were here,
police apprehended
a suspect in the Golden --
the Golden State Killer,
basically.
-They caught
the Golden State Killer.
-And your -- your late wife
had written a book about him.
-Yes.
-I was actually on a book tour.
It was the -- we were
in Chicago, my wife's hometown,
and we did the reading,
and then went to bed.
And at 4:00 a.m., my phone --
Everyone's phone
started pinging,
and we all met in the lobby.
And we're like,
"He's been caught, I think."
And then, I was coming to do
your show that night,
and I'm on the plane.
I think I sent
an Instagram little selfie film,
going, "Well,
I'm gonna go on 'Seth Meyers.'
I think they just caught this
killer my wife was track--"
Like, I didn't know
what the panel was saying,
'cause I was there to tell jokes
and promote a show,
and suddenly,
"We've caught a killer."
It was just weird.
I don't know
how to segue into that.
So it was a very, very --
And when I was on the show,
if you watch that episode,
you can see how sleep-deprived
and freaked out I was.
-Yeah.
-'Cause I didn't --
I didn't know where --
And you were, like,
"What are we gonna talk about?
How do we approach this?"
-Yeah.
-It was very interesting.
-Yes.
-And I --
It's nice now to have you --
How have
the last 10 months been?
I mean,
has it continued to be surreal?
-It's been --
well, weirdly enough, today,
as we're talking,
this is the day
of the paperback
release of the book.
And I wrote a new afterward
that describes that day.
And it ends on this show,
talking about
what I was just talking about,
which was, "How do I do
a segment about a --"
Like, that's not --
That's not what a comedian
normally does
on his talk-show segments.
-Yeah.
-It's talking about --
-But I get mentioned
in the paperback?
-Um...
[ Laughter ]
All right.
You know, it's weird.
There was, uh...
I think your lawyers
didn't want you in there.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-So we had to...
[ Laughter ]
-You just had a birthday.
You turned 50.
Congratulations.
-I just turned 50.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-How is it?
-Thank you.
It's really --
Oh, no.
[ Laughing ]
-Not even waving.
-It's, um...
You know,
I don't mind turning 50.
What I mind is turning 50
in 2019.
-Okay.
-That stinks.
Because the time to turn 50
was in the '50s.
-Uh-huh.
-Because people were okay
with you going, "Oh, you're 50.
You've had a kid.
Well, you just sit down
and start to die.
Just relax,
do a crossword puzzle,
slowly become racist,
and then die."
[ Laughter ]
But in 2019, you turn 50,
and people are like, "You're 50?
Well, get on your mountain bike,
you silver fox.
Let's get going!"
[ Laughter ]
"You've got decades.
We've got goji berries
and alkaline water."
For my birthday --
At my birthday party,
my wife gave me
a mountain bike with --
She made a poster going,
"Here's your mountain bike,
you silver fox."
And now I am a --
I'm riding my bike around,
which is not a good look.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I don't really have --
I look like somebody
shaved a baby panda
and put biking clothes on him,
and I'm just kind of --
There should be
carnival music playing
while I ride my bike around.
[ Laughter ]
That's what it looks like.
So, yeah.
I'm biking now.
God help me.
-God love ya.
-Thank you.
-The clip for "A.P. Bio" --
Full disclosure --
I'm one of the many producers
on this show.
-And thank you for -- yeah.
-I love watching it.
And Paula Pell,
one of your co-stars --
-Good God.
-One of the funniest people
in the world.
-Paula Pell is maybe
the funniest person
I've ever hung out with
in that --
'Cause she's
a brilliant actress,
she's a great writer,
and doing scenes with her,
she will riff --
constantly riff new lines
at the end of the scene --
I don't know when
they're coming in --
and always busts me up.
Always --
That whole thing with the --
We were just supposed
to fist bump,
and then she just started going,
"Oh, I'll catch her."
[ Laughter ]
She did that weird --
And then I kind of
don't know what to do.
And then,
there was one thing she said.
There's a --
Wait a minute.
She riffed this thing.
I can't repeat it,
'cause it's so atrocious
and filthy.
[ Laughter ]
It involved --
It involved
her breasts and syrup that --
She was at a pancake breakfast,
and it's insane.
[ Laughter ]
But she added it
at the end of the scene.
And instead of me
just immediately cracking up,
'cause they can go,
"Cut, let's do it again,"
I stupidly was like,
"I'm gonna keep it together
and finish this scene."
But then I'm doing that weird
kind of talking
when I'm choking.
So, it looks like
I'm having a stroke, basically,
while I'm talking to her.
And then it went way longer.
She is so funny.
And they give her --
The writers give her
the weirdest stuff to do.
And then, she always...
-Yeah.
-...amps it up
to an even better level.
And I --
You and Lorne making sure
that Mike O'Brien's writing
stays as weird as it does...
-You just stay out of the way.
-How do you guys just --
I mean, Mike O'Brien
is truly one of the --
He's such a great creator,
and it's a wonderful show,
and I'm very excited
for it to come back.